[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
ومتابعينا نحيكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها
كالعاده ابرز ملفات اليوم وفي ملفاتنا
لهذا المساء
بدوافع انسانيه وزير الخارجيه المصري في
دمشق ويلتقي الاسد فهل تكسر كارثه الزلزال
عزله سوريا عربيا
في الملف الثاني وامام لجهود الروسيه
لاعاده تاهيل الاسد رفض امريكي اوروبي
لعودته دوليا فما هي شروط الغربي للتراجع
عن رفضه
وفي الملف الثالث الكريملين يرى خطه بيكين
للحلف في اوكرانيا غير قابله للتطبيق
حاليا فهل وادت موسكو خريطه الطريق
الصينيه في مهدها
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى التفاصيل في اول زياره رسميه
له من انطلاق الحرب الاهليه في سوريا وصل
وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري الى دمشق
حيث التقى رئيس النظام السوري بشار الاسد
بالاضافه الى وزير خارجيته فيصل المقداد
وعقب اللقاءات الرسميه اكد شكر على ان هدف
زيارته انساني في المقام الاول لافتا الى
ان بلاده ستستمر في التواصل لدعم الجهد
الانساني سبق هذه الزياره اتصال من الرئيس
المصري بنظيره السوري غداه الزلزال في
تواصل غير مسبوق بين الرجلين زياره شكري
تاتي بينما لا يزال الاسد معزولا
دبلوماسيا على ساحه الدوليه ولا تزال
عضويه سوريا في جامعه الدول العربيه معلقه
منذ الثوره التي انطلقت عام 2011 لتتحول
لاحقا الى حرب اهليه علما ان عددا متزايدا
من الدول الاعضاء في الجامعه العربيه على
راسها العراق يؤيد سوريا عضويتها في
المنظمه
التطبيع مع الاسد يونيو 2022 منظمه الصحه
العالميه تعين سوريا ضمن مجلسها التنفيذي
اكتوبر 2022 الانتربول يعيد دخول سوريا
الى شبكته خلال 2022 دعوات عربيه قادتها
الجزائر ومصر لاعاده عضويه سوريا الى
جامعه الدول العربيه
بعض الهيئات الامميه والدول نسيت اسباب
طرد سوريا وعزلها
اعاده العلاقات مع دمشق تطبيع للفضائع
التي ارتكبها نظام الاسد
نيويورك تايمز ما يحدث في سوريا يكشف
تناقضات وعيوب نظام حقوق الانسان الدولي
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا هنا في
الاستوديو انطوان زهره نائب السابق في
البرلمان اللبناني اهلا بك معنا ومن
القاهره الدكتور عماد جاد عضو لجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه في البرلمان المصي سابقا ومستشار
مركز الاهرام اهلا بكم الكريمين واسمح لي
ان ابدا من القاهره معك دكتور عماد دكتور
عماد هذه هي الزياره تاتي تحت عنوان رئيسي
بحسب تصريحات وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح
شكري وهي
انسانيه بالاساس ولكن يقول البعض بان هذه
الزياره تخرج عن نطاقها الانساني الى
الفضاء السياسي فسؤال المطروح ما الذي
تريده القاهره من هذه الزياره
[موسيقى]
دكتور بانه هذه المساعدات هذه المساعدات
الكل قام بها
يعني مباراه طاوله تبقى في اطار رياضي
ولكن نتحدث عن زياره
رفيع لوزير الخارجيه المصري فالاكيد بان
هذه الزياره الهدف منها كذلك الى جانب
الانسان هو فتح افق سياسي
مؤكد انا كنت عايز اوصل لحضرتك حتى ماتش
البينج بونج اللي انا قلت انه انه بدات به
العلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه اقصد اقول ان
الظروف الموضوعيه كانت مهيئه بحيث تنتظر
حدث ما لكي تبدا المس لكي تبدا العلاقات
او يبدا الاتصالات الاتصالات موجوده
قادتها الجزائر معها اكثر من دوله عربيه
ناقش عوده الجزائر سوريه الى مقعدها في
الجامعه العربيه نوقش ذلك في الجزائر بشكل
واضح الجزائر قادت هذه المبادره بشكل
رئيسي ومعها مصر
ولا ننسى ان عدد كبير حتى من بين دول
الخليج من رؤساء مجالس دول الخليج منها
الامارات وغيرها
كانوا موجودين ضمن الوفد برلمان العربي
اذا استطيع ان اقول ان الظروف الموضوعيه
كانت ناضجه بحيث تبدا هذه الزياره ويبدا
الانفتاح لحساب المسيره يمكن ان نعددها
الدول العربيه ولكن سالتك منك كلمه
الانفتاح حضرتك تتحدث عن انفتاح في حين ان
البعض الاخر يتحدث عن كسر العزله السوريه
في هذا التوقيت سيد انطوان كيف ترى
الموضوع هل يمكن لهذه الزلزال هل يمكن
للدبلوماسيه الكوارث كما تسمى ان تفتح
افاقا جديده وتكسر عزله سوريا
في الواقع اولا بدك تسمحي لي بلحظتين اشكر
استضافه للمره الثالثه بفتره شهر ونصف
واشكر اهتمام بعض اللبنانيين اللي
استفادوا وجودي بلبنان
وعم يفرحوا تساؤلات
هذا الموضوع لا شك انه التضامن الانساني
والشعور الانساني
لا يرقى اليه اي شك ولا يمكن ان يتم
الاعتراض عليه من اي طرف كان نحن الذين
قاسينا ما قاسيناهم من هذا النظام في
سوريا تعاطفنا مع الشعب السوري في محنته
خلال الحرب وفي المحنه الطبيعيه اللي
تعرضنا مؤخرا واللي للتذكير فقط يحكى عن
5000 وبعض وبضعه مئات قتلى سوريين الله
يرحمهم ويشفي المرضى هذا النظام الذي يقود
سوريا
تشرف
باباده 200 ضعف هذا العدد في حربه على
الشعب السوري وبالتالي انه الشعور
الانساني مع الشعب السوري
يتضمن مسانده الشعب السوري
مؤسسه الشعب السوري وليس تعويم النظام
بحجج
قد يكون المصلحه الاستراتيجيه العربيه
تقتضي ان تعد سوريا الى الحضن العربي ولكن
هل شروط العوده التي كان يطرحها العرب
عندما اخرج سوريا بجامعه الدول العربيه
توفرت هل خرجت
هل خرجت يمكن ان اتحدث عنها هل خرجت سوريا
من الحضن لايراني وعدت الى منظومه المصلحه
العربيه المشتركه هل انسحبت ميليشيات
ايران من سوريا هل اعادت سوريا شعبها
المشرب يحكي عن عشر ملايين سوري مشرد
بالداخل والخارج هل اعادت جزءا من هذا
الشعب الى ارضه في المناطق الامنه على
الارض السوريه هل قامت باي مبادره للعوده
الى الحضن العربي وليس الاستفاده من
الامكانات العربيه هذه اسئله مشروعه تطرح
وتطرح خاصه على من استبعد السوريه عن
مقعدها في الجامعه العربيه منذ اذا كان
وجودها في الجامعه مصلحه استراتيجيه
وقوميه عربيه لما خسرتم هذا الوجود ال 12
سنه واذا كان لم يتغير شيء منذ ذلك الحين
الى الان وما زالت في صلب المحور الذي
يعتدي على الامن العربي
ويجند ميليشيات ويعبث في الامر العربي
الايراني طبعا
فما الداعي الى هذا
انقلها لضيفي دكتور عماد دكتور هل تعتقد
بان الوضع الحالي قابل لان يفتح ملفات هذه
الشروط بان يتم التفاوض فيها قبل عوده
النظام السوري الى الحضن العربي ان كانت
هناك نوايا عربيه لعودته ام ان الحسابات
والترتيبات الحاليه يمكن ان تتعدى هذه
الشروط
لا يعني لا استطيع ان اقول
بستاتيكيه الموقف يعني بمعنى انه قد تشترط
دول على اخرى تلبيه مطالب معينه ثم
يتجاوزها الواقع يعني المساله ليست مطلقه
في ذاتها بمعنى انه حصل اللي حصل في سوريا
منذ اللحظه الاولى كان هناك قرار عربي
بالمقاطعه ماذا كانت النتيجه قتل تشريد
لاجئين
تقسيم الاراضي السوريه بحكم الامر الواقع
وتغلغل ايران في مفاصل الدوله السوريه
لا يعني
انطلاقا من الواقع اذا كان
قد يقول لك البعض بان الخسائر جسيمه كذلك
وبان العوده دون شروط قد يكلف حسره للجانب
الذي طالما عرض النظام السوري هكذا يطرح
الموضوع ممن يعارض عوده النظام الس الى
الحضن العربي
انا انا اقوم بالتحليل ولست صنع قرار ولا
متخذ قرار انا حديثي
بالتحليل يقول لانه اذا كانت العشر سنوات
الماضيه بكل ما ترتبت عليه من دماء وتهجير
ومعاناه وتمزيق للارض السوريه وتمكين
ايران من مفاصل الدوله السوريه
ماذا فعل المقاطعه العربيه والحصار العربي
عمقت من الازمه السوريه صحيح لا يعني ابرء
نظام السوري لكن هذا هو الذي حدث
العراق حدث فيها نفس الامر وعانت معاناه
شديده
وحينما انفتح العرب على العراق تم يعني
استعاده العراق تدريجيا بدليل ان رئيس
البرلمان العربي حاليا هو رئيس البرلمان
العراقي وبالتالي ما اود ان اقوله هو ان
علاقات الدول
وسلوكيات القاده ومنطقتنا مليئه
قائم عديده يعني الحرب الاهليه اللبنانيه
ليست ببعيده وقادتها موجودون
ويلعبون ادوار سياسيه
الاخوان ارتكبوا جرائم في مصر يعني عايز
اقول ان السياسه الان المصالح وانا لا
اتصور انه قرار مصري اتصور انه فيه نوع من
التنسيق بدليل ان الزياره جاءت في اليوم
التالي مباشره لزياره البرلمان او وفد
ممثل للبرلمان العربي اذا كان العقد
الماضي نعم قد يعني ولا بعشرات الالاف من
الضحايا والجرحى
والتعذيب
وملايين المهجرين الذين عانوا في سوريا
وعانوا في تركيا ويعانون في لبنان وفي
الاردن من
الشتاء القارص اذا كان هناك امكانيه
لاعاده خيوط الاتصال من جديد للمملمه
الشمل ولا يعني ذلك
عن تعويم نظام او مثل ذلك لا ليس تعويم
فهي فرصه سانحه ليتم ذلك على الاقل لبدء
طرح خطوط تواصل بين كل هذه الدول ولكن سيد
انطوان حضرتك تعلم ويقال بانه في السياسه
ليس هناك صديق دائم وليس هناك عدو دائم
وظيفه يتحدث عن متغيرات ويتحدث عن تاريخ
عاشت سوريا العوده بهذا الشكل في داخل
السوري بهذا النظام وبهذا الاسم ما الذي
سيطر طبعا على هذا الاساس طرحته تساؤلات
ولم اتخذ موقفا من هذا الانفتاح على
السوريه ومعلوم ان محاولات استرداد سوريه
الى الحضن العربي عمرها سنوات وكانت
خليجيه بامتياز للمرحله الاولى ولاحقه من
ضم لها دول اخرى اخر مبادره كانت جزائريه
في في القمه في الجزائر
نحن غايه منانه ان يعود الشعب السوري الى
مساكنه امنه لانه نحن نتحمل عبء كبير جدا
في لبنان
لبناني كبير جدا طاقه لنا على احتماليه من
الن الى لبنان كذلك تكلم سعيد الضيفك عن
الاردن وتركيا وبالتالي هيدي الدول لبنان
تركيا الاردن يتحملون عبء النزوح وليس
قدوم الاستثمارات من الاثرياء السوريين
بعد الحرب في سوريا هون دول يعنيها ان
تنتهي الحرب في سوريا وان تنتهي الازمه
وان تحصل مصالحه وان يعود الجميع الى
مساكنهم هدد الاسئله اللي سالتها هل تعتقد
سيد انطوان بانه في هذه المرحله الحاليه
سيقتصر الموضوع على زيارات على جس نبض على
محاوله لفتح خطوط تواصل ام قد
المسؤولين الذين تهافتوا على النظام
السوري عندما تعرض الشعب السوري لنكمه
جديده على يد الطبيعه وليس على يد النظام
هذا السؤال يوجه لاصحاب القرار الذين
يفتشون عن فرصه للانفتاح على سوريا على
سوريا هل النظام السوري بصدد العوده فعلا
الحضن العربي هو مرحب به اذا كان مستعدا
لذلك اما اذا كان سيستمر ساحه مستباحه
لميليشات ايران وسياستها وتدخلها في
المنطقه فلا اظن ان المصلحه العربيه تقتضي
بتسهيل اموره بهذا الشكل
من خذلان هكذا يقول السوري المعارض هل
تعتقد بانه هذه الزيارات ستفتح الباب لشيء
جديد تفرضه على النظام السوري ليقدم هو
كذلك من جانبه ربما
امكانيه تسويه بعض الامور لمحاوله
الاقتراب اكثر من الدول العربيه وارضاء
داخل السوري كذلك
سيده الفاضله علاقات الدول لا تقوم كما
تفضلتي لا تقوم على مشاعر الحب والكره
تقوم على المصالح سوريا كانت لها مصالح مع
ايران وايران لها مصالح في سوريا حتى
نستطيع ان نخرج سوريا من المحور الايراني
وبالمناسبه ده من ايام الحرب العراقيه
الايرانيه وسوريا كانت في الصف الايراني
من ايام حفظ الاسد الاب فعايز اقول ان
المساله مساله مصالح انا اتصور ان هناك
مصالح عربيه تقتضي الانفتاح على سوريا
اتنين ان هناك مصالح سوريه تقتضي انفتاح
العالم العربي ثلاثه
لا اتصور ولا اعتقد ان النظام السوري بعد
الانفتاح العربي سيكون هو النظام السوري
الذي قامت على يديه الحرب
اربعه لابد من وضع خارطه الطريق لكن انا
يعني خلافي مع ضيفك الكريم في الاستوديو
هو ان المسائل في علاقات الدول لا تو
بشروط مسبقه هي
تستغل ظروف موضوعيه معينه فتبدا العرب
خسروا كلهم جميعا الدول العربيه
ولكن فقط اتفاعل مع حضرتك لما تقول بانه
العلاقات بين الدول لا توضع او لا نبدا
العمل عليها بشروط مسبقه ولكن مثلا لما
نتابع محاوله التقرب التركي من مصر مصر
كانت فرضت شروطها مسبقا على تركيا لمحاوله
بدء الحديث عن تقارب فلماذا ما يفرض على
تركيا لا يفرض على النظام الاسد في هذه
الحاله
لا هقول لحضرتك لان هنا مشكله الاسد مع
شعبه يعني مشكله في الانقسام داخل الشعب
السوري هناك تيارات وافكار وفيها جماعات
متطرفه وفيها سلاح وفيها انصار لتركيا على
الاراضي السوريه وغيره مشكله مصر مع تركيا
ان تركيا كانت بتدعم جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين كانت بتستضيف قنوات تهاجم النظام
المصري للنهار كان اردوغان نفسه بيهاجم
النظام المصري وبيصفه بالانقلاب يعني كانت
مشكلتنا انه يوقف هجومه ويوقف هذا الامر
لكن مع الاسد مشكلته مع شعبه
وبالتالي هنا التدخل العربي اذا كان العشر
سنين اللي فاتوا نتيجه القطيعه لم يستطع
العرب ان يؤثروا واخترقت ايران اكثر العمق
السوري وتمكنت من مفاصل الدوله السوريه
والغارات الاسرائيليه بتتم على مواقع
للحرس الثوري وغيره طيب اذا كان العرب قد
توجهوا للعراق والعراق انفتح واستقبل
العرب واستقبل كاس خليجي 27 هكذا
عاد لو نظرنا للسياسه العراقيه اليوم
سنجيها اكثر توجها ناحيه العرب منه ناحيه
ايران هل بدات تظهر خلافات عراقيه ايرانيه
نفس الامر يمكن الاخير دكتور عماد انتهى
تماما توقيت هذا الملف اعذرني على
المقاطعه بقي لي القليل اترك لك سيده
انطوان في تعليق يعني اذا كان هذا المنطق
صحيحا
فان العرب قد اخطاوا بقطع بقطعتهم مع نظام
السوري لسنوات طويله وخسروا كثيرا نتيجه
سياسه المقاطعه لنظام السوري كان الاجدب
بهم ان لا ان لا يفرضوا هذه القطيعه على
النظام وان يستفيدوا من قدراته استراتيجيا
ويسرد من الحضن الايراني بس هذا كلام
تبريري ليس كلاما واقعيا التجارب ماثله
امامنا وبرجع بعيد منذ اللحظه الاولى في
اكد لي كان في رفض خليجي لاسقاط النظ في
سوريا خوفا من ان يكون البديل تطرفا
اسلاميا وبالتالي لم يسعوا الى اسقاط
النظام في سوريا ولكن هذا النظام كان مثل
ما تفضل ضيفك الكريم من القاهره منذ ايام
حافظ الاسد في الحرب الايرانيه العراقيه
اين كان كان في صف ايران وبالتالي هذا
خياره استراتيجي
وكلامه عن
العرب والعلاقات العربيه والاخره مجرد
مصلحه معترف نعم الدول لها مصالح وليس
عواطف ولكن عمليا ان شاء الله يكون
الاتجاه الان الى عكس هذا المسار لانه
كلنا بنرتاح بالعالم العربي
ولكن هناك ذلك بوصله المجتمع الدول التي
سنناقش توجهاتها بعد قليل ساكتفي معكما
بهذا القدر شكرا جزيلا زهره النائب السابق
في البرلمان اللبناني وشكر كذلك لحظرتك من
القاهره دكتور عماد جاد عضو لجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه في البرلمان المصري سابقا
ومستشار مركز الاهرام شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]